Okay, some questions. How often can you take the right programs that get rid of parasites?
How often can you use the right programs that can be rid of parasites?
So the parasite programs, like the All Bugs Kill program and some of the other very specific parasite programs,
you could literally run those 24-7 if you wanted to.
Well, not suggesting you do that because you want to be running your cancer programs.
But parasites don't have what you have to be careful with with other programs.
There's really only the certain bacterial programs that will cause herb cyber reactions.
And that I would say it's not wise to do too much of those.
Those are typically live programs.
So live the Borrelia Berberdorfia bacteria as a grand negative bacteria that has life of polysaccharides in the cell membranes.
And if you kill a grab negative bacteria too quickly, you will liberate a lot of life of polysaccharides.
It will stimulate the immune system reaction that if you have an auto immune disease can make, can really cause a flare.
We don't deal with that with cancer patients.
So that's not what we're talking about, but cancer patients can also have live disease.
And if you're going to run a lot of live programs, you could herb cyber give yourself a first reaction, which is not what you want to do.
You will not do that when you run parasite programs that will not happen when you run cancer program.
So you can run those as often as you want.